hello and welcome to this video clang NM
just wrong just follow currently based
in Bangkok okay yeah that stuff attack
that's the thai Flag n slow the ratty
system very solid opening it for both
sides black ass excellent chance here to
equalize then we will quite often get
pay import 15 points but so black it's
crucial to get the timing right now see
five would be wrong he has to wait a
little bit down okay i like to transfer
the night 33 here so not easy for them
to play c5 yeah III is really good sorry
supporting both I still think if I this
to earlier I can take on c5 and play
Knight f4 and define is under too much
pressure
already has a couple of simple
strengthening moves hoop group the
eighth for example is one of them so
probably probably want to move my queen
out of the way
I'm not sure c5 now is on I can't play
something else entirely mmm that I can
actually take and then go 95 tonight
takes pawn takes Bishop takes Bishop
takes Queen takes Queen c7 this should
be a somewhat better ending for white
and then currently attacking e-form make
sure if you can avoid this ending here
96 is also a threat maybe makes c5 work
somehow remember I can take on your form
yeah I can take on you for them or take
on d7 also not bad wow really and Quincy
for Quincy for any has to go to f8 yes I
mean I will go to c6 anyway just like
amazing that you would accept this kind
of thing again I go here anyway I don't
have a tactical solution but this is
very good strategically speaking see
bonus under file and some light squares
are very weak
okay so i don't know if doubling on the
sea far really Nets much is the most
obvious thing to do so in one of our big
issues is that i try to be too young to
try to go for the maximum and get to
punish bad play and sometimes i just
spent too much time and then i cannot
finish it off so sometimes probably
simply moves would actually score better
okay so Queen h6 was probably what he
wants to do
and I can just send it back up don't see
why not I take a six is ready f-for
maybe I've for you we'll play it for
anyway trying to swindle yeah Bishop c4
probably all the should be five it is
also pretty strong look at this book
and it's actually true not not really
not such a successful maneuver here you
can go a form no doesn't
and the wife I have misplayed that I
really miss played that it's not clear
now how I'm doing stuff on the sea farm
amazing
it's pretty remarkable
you
93 Bishop e2 should be okay I don't I
mean I probably have to play Bishop a
threesome how I don't see how I can I
open open the position otherwise this
just helps me I mean I get the H file
now that's the bishop won't be too
check
and just keep the Victorian o ok ty
morning hey defense quite well here ok
it's ok for me to also win on time once
in a while check oh I didn't see that
oops yeah I just didn't see that was
protected ok black forfeit on time ok
and there was strange very strange that
all of a sudden I mean in this solution
really when I when I get here what black
is just busted normally but i didn't i
didn't prove it I mean he's got
weaknesses all over the place and I
would f3 that was the that was the
engine move past it open and I played it
too slowly i mean it looks good but
sorry ok it looked good what I did but
it was so so too so slow inspire now you
don't quite know how you win their queen
a for Bishop e3 was good that's an idea
that I like for here now that looks
excellent actually I didn't understand
that this moment that I need to be sure
to betrayed it what I did here is just
doing nothing it so bad
and then it still gives me some
advantage because it is still better and
just like I spent so much time i get f
for now no if I think nothing great okay
now why is winning by material yeah I
didn't really like pay close attention
as winning on time I completely
overlooked that he can take it I mean I
was just thinking okay six is a good
move here I'm still a lot better with
normal moves but I didn't see would be
six that it was saying just an
elucidation I was very surprised to
detect f6 in this position that's really
not necessary you can I mean this ending
is not fun young but f6 is really giving
giving wide lock em there's this knight
c6 business ok guys thanks for watching